على كل المزيد تنتمي الي مراسله صباح
العربيه الريان الظاهر وضيفها مهران اهلا
بك يا ريان عارفين على مهران تفضلوا
يسعد صباحك بالخير سهام قلت له عليكم
اليوم همم من النافذه مختلفه وصلت فيها
الضوء على احد ابناء سوريا الحبيبه عاشقا
نجاره منذ نعومه اظافره ابدع واحترف في
هذه المهنه من عامل في احد المصانع الى
صاحب همم اهم همم واحد من من اميه زي
المصانع في منطقه الخرطوم صناعه الاثاثات
وان جاره والواح الخشب بالتاكيد نتعرف على
مهران مصمص الذي اتخذ السودان موطنا
لاحلامه كانت له يسعد صباحك بالخير مهران
اهلا وسهلا فيك يا رب تشرفنا فيك كلمني عن
عشقك لمهنه النجاره الصغيره
حبي لا اله
ربيع جاموس سوريا فصرت العراق كل يوم
اتفرج كيف يصنع الاساسات وكده فكان عم
بعشقك
العابي وكده وزاره الطموح
يعني من عام ايضا مصنع في مصنع
المصانع في منطقه الخرطوم بحري كيف حققت
هذا الحلم
الى هذه الشغله وتميز في السودان لاثود
اثبات وجودنا في السودان كمان
ممكن تلاقي بعد الصعوبات شنو
الصعوباتنا السودانيين
[موسيقى]
مهران
انواع الخشب كيف الاسعار
طيب الزباين بيحبوا المجامله يعني العميل
احيانا بيحبوا يتفاوت في الاسعار في في
ممكن
عندنا مهران
شكرا مهران عوده لكما سهام ونادين
عاشقه للمونديال برايك ما انت رايحين
المغرب فرنسا اليوم فنيه
بعيدا عطيه
طبعا اكيد سهام اول حاجه نحب نشجع على
المنتخب المغربي بكل تاكيد هذا المنتخب
الافريقي والعربي بالتاكيد كونه يصل لنصف
نهائي مونديال قطر 20 22 فهذا فخر لكل
العرب والافارقه بكل تاكيد ركراك عقليه
كرويه نفخر ونعتز جدا بها اللاعبين ايضا
هي مباراه بالتاكيد صعبه عن المنتخب
الفرنسي الديوك همم بصراحه اصحاب اللقب في
كاس العالم مونديال روسيا 2018 فبالتاكيد
هي مباراه صعبه لكن باي حال من الاحوال
نتمنى الفوز المغاربه من الاخر مع مين يا
ريان
من الاخر الهوى مغربي يعني بالتاكيد وان
كانت المباراه دي عزيزه علي جدا يعني على
فكره لانه انا مشجعه للضيوف من زين الدين
زيدان 2006 يعني هم يتكلم عن مونديال 2006
بنتكلم عن الاساطير
بنتكلم عن زين الدين زيدان حاليا بنزيما
افضل لاعب في العالم
كل هذه التفاصيل اعشق
بنزيما لا يلعب لا يلعب الان طبعا
لا اعتقد انه سيشركه في المباريات القادمه
بالتوفيق للمنتخب المغربي
من البرازيل يا ريان بس بحب اذكرك رونالدو
بيكي ودموع كانت بكل مكان بكل عناوين
الاخبار والصحف بس
رونالدو
مثل المباراه العزيزه اليوم شكرا ريان
الظاهر حدثنا شكرا الريان تنورينا دائما